(whoosh, click, beep)
- So before we get
started, I'm gonna tell you
just a little bit about me
just to kinda let you know
the perspective and
the mindset that I have
and where I come from,
why I have that mindset.
And I'll start with
kind of a personal note.
My wife is here with me, Frasian, and...
(audience applauds)
We've been married for over 30 years,
but we have three children,
and our youngest is special needs.
He is diagnosed with both intellectual
and some physical disabilities,
and he's 22 years old.
And from a parental perspective, you know,
I've been in law enforcement,
this is my 30th year
in law enforcement, and
from a parental perspective,
I know probably many of you who either
have somebody in your family,
you have one of your loved
ones that you're close to,
or many of you who have
special needs in the audience,
me, being in this line of work,
one of the things that I think about often
is what would happen
if my son, if our son,
came in contact with law enforcement,
and how would he react
if we're not around,
or his brothers and
sisters, some other person,
is not around to guide him
through that encounter.
And I do, and my wife as well,
think about that quite often.
On the other side, from a
professional perspective,
it always crosses my mind about
what can we do to get better?
What can I do?
Now, particularly, now
that I'm in this position,
what can I personally do
to make the situation better for others.
And I think there's a
lot of work to be done
in this regard, and I'm really happy
and pleased that the San
Francisco Police Department
is taking steps in that direction
to really make our
interactions and our encounters
with people and persons with
intellectual disabilities
and physical disabilities, to
make those encounters better.
So that's gonna be the focus
of my presentation today,
and it's a PowerPoint, but
I will kind of interject.
There's some videos that are here,
and some of them are
pretty, pretty intense,
to say the least, but the reason I want
to show those videos to
you is because the issues
that we're discussing
are issues that really
can amount to life and death situations
if we, law enforcement, police officers,
don't handle them properly.
So, as I said, there is a
personal component to this for me.
I'm personally vested in this,
and the bottom line on the vision
that you'll hear about shortly is,
you know, we wanna get better,
we wanna be, we, the San
Francisco Police Department,
I think law enforcement in general,
we want to do this right in terms of
being able to deliver
services to everybody
that we come in contact, disabled or not.
So that will be the focus
of this presentation.
So, disclosure, there's nothing
for me to disclose really.
I'm not being paid for this presentation.
There's no fees attached to this.
I'm doing it strictly because
I want us to make a difference.
So here's our overview.
In the past few years,
spotlight has been basically
on negative police encounters,
particularly with persons in mental crisis
and debilitating, often
time, long-term illnesses,
and that includes
persons with intellectual
and developmental disabilities.
And there are similarities
between mental health crisis
and sometimes those with intellectual
and developmental disabilities,
particularly when those
interactions go sour.
Oftentimes, the
disabilities are manifested
by triggers, and we end up
with a crisis situation.
These differences require
different responses
from those used on persons in crisis.
Now, there's a need to
implement policies, procedures,
develop effective training,
and provide additional services
through partnerships to improve the lives
of vulnerable populations,
as well as their families.
And when I get further
in the presentation,
I'm gonna show you all some statistics
about just how vulnerable
this population is,
and it's really eye-opening.
So what do we wanna do today?
We wanna express our vision.
We wanna learn from our past experiences.
And we wanna realize change.
So in doing so, we wanna
discuss and explain to you,
and I'm gonna, this is
from a San Francisco
Police Department perspective,
and I know there's a
lot going on nationwide
in law enforcement,
but I'm gonna keep this
on more in a local perspective
when I talk about vision.
We really want to be more effective
in how we respond to calls
involving, and encounters,
involving those with intellectual
and developmental disabilities.
Some of the past
experiences that you'll see,
well, we have a few videos, as I stated,
and they'll illustrate
why we need to change,
and why we need to realize
change in this body of work.
And we'll highlight what changes
law enforcement in general,
and the San Francisco Police
Department, are making
to ensure that we treat everyone
that we come in contact with
with dignity and respect.
So in short, our vision
is we want to be of help
to those who rely upon
us in their time of need.
And in doing so, we have to develop
a greater understanding
of the characteristics
and behaviors that
persons with intellectual
and developmental
disabilities may present,
and the steps to minimize
potential safety risks
of this vulnerable population
during encounters with us.
Now in order to realize that vision,
we really have to have
a better understanding
of those with special needs,
and then train to it, train to incorporate
that understanding into
our service delivery.
Here's a snippet of a San
Francisco Police Department
training video designed
to better understand,
and before I even go foreword,
I wanna point out in the audience,
I have Captain Melinda Moore,
and if you will raise your hand, Melinda.
I just wanna give her,
(audience applauds)
just wanna give her some kudos,
because she has poured her heart and soul
into really improving us as a department,
and what, the videos
that you're about to see,
and I'm gonna show you several snippets,
but this is the first of several,
would not have happened
without Melinda's energy
and her commitment to this issue.
So thank you, Melinda.
John, please play the video.
- I like shiny objects.
I like the reflection of people's glasses,
but I'm not trying to
invade their safety zone.
- Do you wanna do one more?
Is there anything else
that applies to you?
- Number 12: sometimes
people on the spectrum
laugh at unusual times.
They just do it.
I don't know why.
They're not mocking anyone.
- Okay, well, it says,
hi, are you ready now?
- [Man Off Camera] Yes, I am.
- Okay, it says, hi, I'm Andrew,
and I'm on the spectrum.
You might notice my voice is kind of loud.
That's just the way I am.
I'm not being belligerent,
belligerent, right.
- [Woman Off Camera] Do you
wanna try it one more time?
- Uh, but I've already done it.
- Hi, I'm Jim Allray.
I have a diagnosis of Asperger's syndrome.
People who are such are called
Aspsy and are often weird,
and so by the transitive
property, I'm a certified weirdo.
What it is is I have no facial expression.
- My name is Paco Lorenzo Melgar.
Then also I am very sensitive to touch.
It can be very painful,
so I might pull away.
I'm not fighting or resisting.
- Some people on the spectrum might seem
a little uncoordinated.
That doesn't mean that
they're drunk or on drugs.
- Autistics are usually
honest and literal.
They're not trying to
be rude or sarcastic.
- I was meditating,
actually, in a building,
a public building, an empty building,
on UCFS campus, and I was approached
by a security officer there from behind.
I had my ear plugs in at the time,
because I have sensory issues,
and I did not hear the
police officer talking to me,
and he thought I was giving him attitude.
When he finally came
around in front of me,
and I saw what was going on.
So, that was an unintentional
miscommunication
because of a sensory issue
that I was dealing with using earplugs.
I want to say something
general, though, also,
which is that I feel that
many people on the spectrum,
some of them have positive experiences
and some negative experiences
interacting with the police,
but overall, I think we're all aware
of how important the police are
in keeping our society safe for us,
and this applies especially
to people on the spectrum,
that we are very aware
of what an important role
you are playing in keeping
the streets generally safe,
much safer than they would be without you.
So thank you for that.
That's it.
(audience applauds)
- So as you can see, what
we're trying to do here
is gain understanding
and give our officers
a better understanding.
Now, people like me, I like
to think that I get it,
having 22 years of experience as a parent
with a child with special needs,
but we know that there
are a lot of officers
that are out in the field that
don't have that experience.
And so this type of training,
these types of videos,
as simple as it might sound,
can make a world of difference
in how we deal with an encounter
when we come in contact
with an individual with intellectual
or developmental disabilities.
Most of our actions as police officers
are a reflection of our
training and our experiences.
It's really essential that
we study past incidents
to better understand the importance
of differentiating between
those in a mental or physical
health crisis and those with
an intellectual disability.
And it's really a discernible difference
that we have to be better at.
Unfortunately, some of the
outcomes of law enforcement
experience with special needs
populations have not been good
and they have been met with
really disastrous results.
I'm gonna show you a video,
some of you may have seen this,
of a gentleman by the
name of Ethan Saylor,
and just to set the background.
This happened in January of 2013.
Ethan was a 26 year old
young man, and he died,
actually, after an encounter
with police officers.
Ethan had been diagnosed
with Down syndrome,
and basically, that particular evening,
he went to the movies and saw the movie
that he wanted to see,
and decided that he wanted
to see it again, so he attempted
to re-enter the theater.
The manager of the
theater called the police,
and three off-duty Frederick County
sheriff's deputies responded.
And now, John, let's roll the video.
(somber music)
- [Announcer] Too many times,
people with disabilities
come into contact with the
criminal justice system,
and the outcome is anything but just.
Misunderstandings and miscommunications
lead to cracks in the system.
Pathways to justice become
impossible to navigate.
Ethan, a young man with Down syndrome,
was excited to see a movie.
When the movie ended, he
tried to re-enter the theater,
because he hoped to see a second showing.
Ethan's first contact with
the criminal justice system
came as a suspect when this
was reported as a crime.
Three off-duty police officers responded
to the theater manager's complaint,
and despite requests from
Ethan's support staff to wait,
things got physical.
The exact sequence of
events is in dispute,
but before the evening
ended, Ethan was dead,
due to asphyxiation
when in prone restraint.
Ethan fell through the cracks,
and as a result, lost his life.
Things could've turned out differently.
- Now, as I said, some
of these videos are hard
to grapple with, but just a few
more facts about this video.
As an aside, an aide was with Ethan,
and told officers that
Ethan's mother was on her way.
The aide further advised the officers
that if touched, Ethan
would basically freak out.
The officers, in response, told the aide
to leave the theater and not to interfere.
Then the officers grabbed Ethan,
which resulted in him cursing at them,
Ethan cursing at the officers,
and the struggle ensued from there.
Ethan fell to the ground
with a deputy on top of him,
and that's when he stopped breathing.
We have to learn from these outcomes.
We have to learn from these tragedies
to get a better response and to prevent
subsequent catastrophic
failures as this one was.
So how do we get better?
Better discernment, as we call it
in law enforcement, situational awareness.
Knowing what you have in front of you.
That only comes with training.
So to get better in discernment,
one of the avenues where the San Francisco
Police Department is really focusing on
is identifying and being
able to distinguish
a person in a mental health crisis
versus a person with a disability
that's causing this type of response.
Unlike incidents involving a person
in a mental or physical crisis,
there's really not been
a concentrated focus on
specifically addressing
persons with an intellectual,
developmental disability
in law enforcement.
And although the current
training to respond
to persons in crisis is fairly effective,
we need to recognize
that although similar,
there is a big difference,
a marked difference,
between persons considered
in a mental health
or health crisis and
those with an intellectual
or developmental disability,
and that these differences
may require a different response.
And going back to Ethan's situation,
I don't know what training
those officers had,
and it's not fair for me
to judge them on that,
but what I do know is in those situations,
the better training you have,
the better understanding you have,
the better off you are
in terms of dealing with
and effectively handling those encounters.
As a result of Ethan's
incident, the Maryland governor
created a commission and developed
a statewide training
standard for law enforcement
in Maryland and first
responders to interact
with people with disabilities.
So, how do we distinguish
persons in crisis
versus developmental disabilities?
First, let me start with
what the definition of those.
A situation in which a person experiences
an intensive behavioral, emotional,
or psychiatric response triggered
by a precipitating event.
I'm sorry, can't even say the word.
That's a health crisis.
You know, the person
may be at risk of harm
to self or others, disoriented,
or out of touch with reality,
functionally compromised,
and otherwise agitated,
unable to be calmed down.
If the crisis is left untreated,
it can result in a
mental health emergency.
Now, we come in contact,
particularly in the city
and county of San Francisco,
we come in contact
with this situation quite a bit.
You know, these incidents
can lead to suicide
due to depression, a lot of times.
They're really aggravated
by substance abuse,
by untreated psychiatric
disorders, PTSD, et cetera.
There's a large spectrum of
issues that we come across.
But there's really a
need to understand that
as opposed to a person
who's intellectually
or developmentally disabled,
and that disability
is what's driving the behavior,
as opposed to a crisis caused
by psychosis from drugs
or some other mental health breakdown.
It's really important to discern,
because our response
can be the difference,
as we saw in the last video,
between life and death.
It's that serious for us.
The definition of intellectual disability:
these disorders are
characterized by limited
mental capacity and difficulty
with adaptive behaviors,
behaviors such as
managing money, schedules,
routines, social interactions.
They generally appear
before the age of 18,
and may result from physical
causes such as autism,
cerebral palsy, or from
non-physical causes such as
a lack of stimulation
and adult responsiveness.
Developmental disabilities,
severe long-term disabilities
that can affect cognitive abilities,
physical functioning, or both.
Now generally they appear
before the age of 22
and are likely to be lifelong.
Here is a tip, and I wanna
go back to this video
that we saw a second ago
with Ethan, with the aide.
The aide that was there to help,
the aide that was there
to give information that,
had it been listened
to, may have prevented
that situation from escalating,
one of the things that
it's sometimes difficult
for police officers to do,
particularly in the heat
of the moment, is slow down.
Slow down and listen.
And oftentimes we get in the situation
where we believe
somebody's life is at risk,
or safety is at risk, and it's all about
stabilizing the situation,
but we've learned over time,
particularly those of us
that've been around for a while,
that we have to step back,
and we really do have to slow things down.
And we're gonna talk a little bit more
in future slides about
how we are doing that.
Getting back to some of the signs
of developmental disability.
Some people may be solely physical,
such as blindness from birth.
Others may involve physical
and intellectual disabilities
stemming from a genetic or other causes
such as Down syndrome or
fetal alcohol syndrome.
There's a characteristic that I learned,
particularly from my personal
experience with our son.
When he was younger, there
were no outward signs
that he was disabled.
He looked like a normal child.
And as soon as you interacted with him,
you could quickly figure out
that that wasn't the case,
but there is a population
out there of many people
that are intellectually and
developmentally disabled
where on first appearance,
you can't tell the difference.
That's a much harder population for,
particularly for law enforcement officers,
because you really have to know
what you're looking for, number one.
You really have to know
the cues, number two.
Number three, you really
have to be trained.
If you don't have a personal
experience like I do,
you really have to
understand and know that
just because a person looks
like a typical individual,
they may not be.
And that processing has
to happen pretty quickly
in a volatile situation.
This is why we have to train.
This is why it's so
important to have videos
like what Captain Moore put together,
so our officers have an
awareness of what to look for.
I'm gonna segue into use of force,
because oftentimes, when we
don't know what to look for,
those encounters turn
into what we don't want,
and that's physical
force having to be used
by police officers on a
person with a developmental
or intellectual disability.
And we know that when,
many times when police
are called to incidents involving a person
with an intellectual or
developmental disability,
because of a perceived threat or concern,
due to the oftentimes,
the disability itself,
is really difficult to distinguish.
Like I said, some people,
there's no outwardly signs
of any type of disability.
And those are much more
difficult to deal with
from a policing perspective.
And whether this call for
service is self-initiated,
or whether officers are
responding to a dispatch call
for service, our training needs to focus
on slowing things down.
There's a saying that I
learned early on in policing
in my career: time is on your side.
If you can slow things down,
you're gonna be better off.
And that's a learned skill,
because when you're in
the heat of the moment,
and you roll up on a call, and it's chaos,
oftentimes, you react based
on what your training is,
what your experience is,
but sometimes you have to
kind of collect yourself, and
you have to slow things down.
That is the mode of training that is
on the forefront of law enforcement.
As simple as it sounds, and
as basic as this sounds,
easier said than done.
Slowing things down,
create time and distance.
Understanding the
possibility that a disability
may be a contributing factor is key,
and responding accordingly
to the overall situation,
not the initial perception, is also key.
A little bit, statistically speaking,
about police use of force.
Now, the chart that
you see in front of you
kind of breaks down, research
shows that approximately 25%,
some say as high as 50%,
of persons killed by police
may have a mental disorder,
or that person was
in a mental health crisis,
including under the influence
of a controlled substance
during this encounter.
Now, what I believe, as a professional,
as a chief of police sitting
here in front of you,
that hidden in those
numbers are a lot of people
with developmental disabilities.
And with over 18,000 police departments
across the country, and really
no national standardization
of what has to be tracked
and needs to be tracked,
we don't really know what that number is,
to be quite frank with you.
And it is my hope that before
I leave this profession
that we do a better job,
because with anything,
when you have data and research,
then you can start figuring out
what you need to do to make things better.
We just don't have the
data on this subject.
Incidents involving
individuals with disabilities
and developmental or intellectual,
they go under the radar,
to be quite frank with you,
because we're not really capturing it.
Sorry about that.
I skipped ahead too
far, give me one...okay.
Here are more statistics,
and basically, what this graph shows
is as the number of calls
for service involving
persons in crisis increase,
law enforcement reexamine
the basic training philosophies
and standard operating procedures
to adjust our response,
the officers' response to incidents
involving a person in crisis.
And the whole spirit behind that was
we wanna minimize getting to a situation
where we have to use force,
oftentimes when force can be prevented
if we know what the situation
is that we're facing.
The San Francisco Police
Department in 2015,
we really kind of stepped
up our game and expanded
our effort, including our
crisis intervention training,
to better understand how to
deal with persons in crisis.
Now this doesn't specifically
speak with the intellectual
and developmental disabilities training,
but just better training on how to deal
with a person in crisis was a good step
in the right direction for us,
because in that, now we are
specifically focusing more
on the other side of it, you know,
how much of this is due to developmental
or intellectual disabilities?
You know, the changes that were included.
Slowing things down, you're gonna hear me
say that over and over again.
Creating time and distance.
If you have to use force,
use a proportional amount
of force, an amount of
force that's reasonable.
Increasing our training techniques
to reinforce de-escalation.
And basically limiting
force against people
that are only a danger to themselves.
Also, tools of the trade, we
have new tools of the trade,
extended range impact weapons
where we don't have to
necessarily use lethal force
when we do get beyond a situation
that can be handled through
de-escalation or verbal techniques.
What can we do short of lethal force?
So all these things I think have helped us
really reduce our use of force,
and since 2015, our use
of force in San Francisco
is down about 27% overall.
But again, we have to do
better in really calling out
the developmental disability issues,
because we really don't know what
that number is, to be
quite frank with you.
So when an incident involves a person
with an intellectual or
developmental disability
that at times may present characteristics
that are considered aggressive, violent,
such as with certain types of conditions
like Asperger's, and you
know, the mere presence
of a a police officer in uniform
may trigger an unwanted response.
the next video that I'm gonna show you
is an incident, and it's one
that's pretty intense as well.
Charles Kinsey, and just to set this up,
some of you have seen this.
This was July 18, 2016, and
this was in Miami, Florida.
Mr. Kinsey was a social worker,
and during this incident,
he was actually shot
by police in north Miami, Florida.
Mr. Kinsey was actually dealing with
and trying to help a
23-year-old autistic man,
and Kinsey had gone to the care facility
to locate this man, who
had been reported missing.
A summary of the event shows that officers
were dispatched to a report
of a person with a gun
threatening to shoot himself.
Upon arrival, officers
attempted to gain compliance,
yet the person with the object
that was believed to be
a gun refused to obey.
John, if you would please play the video.
That's Mr. Kinsey laying on the ground,
and the other individual, sitting,
is the person with the developmental
and intellectual disability.
- [Charles Kinsey] Arnaldo, please,
please be still, Arnaldo.
Get down, Arnaldo, lay
on your stomach, Arnaldo.
- [Man Off Camera] He's
like, please don't shoot me.
- [Woman Off Camera] But
why they shot the black boy
and not the fat boy?
- [Man Off Camera] Because
he was black, you know?
- [Woman Off Camera] I
don't know who's guilty.
- So, the therapist was on
the ground with his hands up.
Again, the therapist is there to help.
Now, I will say this,
I don't wanna get into
right or wrong or what
happened on that shooting,
but what I do know about this is
slowing things down, listening.
You know, the therapist, I
think you saw in the video,
he was pointing out that
what was in the man's hand
was a toy truck, actually.
And the officers never
processed that information,
apparently, and they felt that a life
was being threatened, and
it resulted in tragedy.
Now, Mr. Kinsey was the one
that was ultimately shot
by the police, and he
survived his injuries,
but again, understanding, you know,
I don't know that the officers really knew
what they had in front of them.
And this is why understanding
is vitally important
for us to not have this happen.
It's a tragedy, and we have to get better.
We have to learn from
these types of incidents
to get better, to be better at what we do.
So how do we do that?
How do we realize changes?
Now, as I talked about, you know,
when I put on my father hat,
and having a child with a developmental
and intellectual disability,
I think about this.
I think about it often.
I, what's gonna happen, I
can't be there all the time.
My wife can't be there all the time.
But we can make a difference,
we in law enforcement, people
like me and Captain Moore
and others, many others,
we can make a difference,
to make sure we have
the best understanding
that if we encounter, that
we do the best job we can
to try not to have a tragedy occur.
And those encounters happen daily.
They happen in many ways, casual,
people asking for directions,
public event or just
walking down the street,
people being a victim
or witness of a crime,
people being suspects, person of interest.
And it's not to say that people
with developmental
disabilities don't get involved
in criminal activity, because
sometimes that does happen,
and that's another side of this story
that we have to be better at,
really understanding
how to deal with that.
And a person being the
subject of an encounter,
when that call is
dispatched by a bystander
that is seeing something that they believe
is criminal activity
or suspicious activity,
and we get dispatched
to calls all the time,
and we're gonna talk a little bit about
some of the issues concerning that,
particularly when it
comes to implicit bias.
This is a vulnerable
population, as I said before,
and you can see on the chart before you,
the information gathered, this came from
the United States Bureau of Justice.
It indicates that between 2011 and 2015,
the rate of violent victimization
against persons with disability
was two and one half times
higher than it was for
persons without disabilities.
Persons between age of 12
and 15 had the highest rate
of victimization than any other age group.
It's a vulnerable population,
which is why we have to be on top of this,
we who come in contact with
the victims and the witnesses,
we have to be on top of this.
In terms of encounters
with law enforcement,
we also know that persons
with intellectual,
intellectual disabilities
may be more easily targeted
for victimization because
they are vulnerable.
People can be manipulated,
and they are less likely or
able to report victimization,
because the perpetrator is a friend.
Now that is a big problem.
A lot of people, because
they do feel isolated,
or feel like they don't have friends,
are really over-reaching to find a friend.
And sometimes that's taken advantage of.
As a parent, I worry
about that all the time.
People just wanna be,
feel like anybody else,
want a friend, want somebody
that I can talk to and rely on,
and there are people out
there that prey on that,
and it's a problem for us,
and it's a problem for
us in law enforcement,
and it's a problem for us as parents,
because it's something that
sometimes you just can't,
as much as you talk to your child,
or as law enforcement,
as much as we train,
we can't control people
who wanna prey upon
a vulnerable population,
so it's something that
we have to deal with in law
enforcement and as parents.
So we're gonna go into a
little bit about subjects
or people that are determined
to be persons of interest.
Now, this next slide, it'll
be probably a little bit
surprising to some of you, and some of you
probably already know this.
Incarceration of Americans
with disabilities,
now this also came from the
Bureau of Justice statistics,
and if you look at the slides,
very, very high percentages of people
who are incarcerated have disabilities.
That is very alarming for many reasons.
But it illustrates why it's so important
for us police officers
to train, to understand,
and maybe to turn these numbers
in a different direction.
But that is a very alarming statistic.
Studies show that people
with developmental
and intellectual disabilities
are overrepresented
in the criminal justice system.
They represent two to three percent
of the general population,
and four to 10 percent of
incarcerated persons overall.
What that means to us is
during a normal shift,
we're likely to come across somebody
with an intellectual or a
developmental disability.
Sometimes we can ferret that
out based on our training,
sometimes we can't.
So when we're taking or
encountering a person
with disabilities,
intellectual or developmental,
into custody, we have
to give particular care
to the manner in which
the person is placed
in physical custody if those
disabilities are physical,
because if we don't, it
can elicit a response
that can be unpredictable
and, quite frankly, unwanted.
The issue here is that
sometimes the person
cannot articulate what
those disabilities are.
And when I talk about slowing
down and taking extra time,
it's really important
for us, when we really,
at the time we determine
that we're dealing
with somebody with an intellectual
or a developmental
disability, you really do have
to spend extra time.
You really do.
My son has some
developmental malformities,
not so sure that he would
be able to articulate that
if an officer were to
place him in handcuffs,
to be quite frank with you.
And if he doesn't, it
could be harmful to him.
So we know that's an issue.
And it goes back to understanding,
and you're gonna see another
training video in a second,
in a few minutes,
rather, about recognition
and understanding, because
we have to spend extra time
to get the information that
we need in order for us
to do the right job and a good job.
So that takes communication,
it takes patience,
and it really takes understanding
and being able to recognize
what we're looking at.
Now, here's another snippet, as I said,
of a training video
that'll help us get better
at our encounters with individuals
with intellectual or
developmental disabilities.
John, if you could play this one.
- You could be helping them,
they could've been missing for days,
they could've just come out of
a really dangerous situation,
and they're unaware that
you're trying to help them.
Try not to look like
you're corralling them,
but do that in a stealth-like way
so you can cut off the running route.
'Cause they wanna get
back to their comfort zone
for the moment, and it's, momentarily,
that's all they're thinking about.
Be very careful as first responders,
we know that the person affected by autism
is either in a combative
state, a highly anxious mode,
motivated by seeking their comfort zone.
So they are doing everything they can
to get away from us and the stimulus.
Kill the lights in the
car, kill the siren,
maybe lower the radios, and
maybe find the calmest person
within your responding
group to do the talking.
Loud noises, loud voices, commanding talk
is something they're gonna shy away from.
You'll get better results
with a calmer voice.
- Now, as you saw, Officer Padilla has a,
he's the father of a child with autism.
Like me, many of us who live this,
have a better understanding,
so one thing about
this profession, the police profession,
there's no better trainer, if
you wanna illustrate a point,
than another police officer,
'cause cops tend to listen to other cops.
So to have people, ah, it's true.
(audience laughs)
But to have, you know,
an officer like Padilla,
or even some of the other
people in our department,
officers in our department,
sworn and civilian,
who can really take their life experiences
and translate that in a
relatable way to training
is really, really important.
This video was really well
received by our force,
and these are the type things that we have
to continue to do to get better.
'Cause it's all about understanding.
You know, I talked about caregivers.
I perfectly understand
that, if I'm dealing with
a person with disabilities,
sometimes I might not need
to be talking to that person.
I might need to be talking to the person,
the caregiver, or the person, the aide
who can better articulate,
who has a better understanding of
what the disabilities are
and can articulate to me
what I need to know to do my job.
So having officers like
Padilla on the police force
really are helpful.
Having people like Captain Moore
really are helpful to get that message
across to the other
officers who don't have
those personal experiences,
so it's a really, really important
piece of training for us.
And I'm really proud that we're
taking the steps to do this.
Interviews with suspects
or persons of interest,
now, I was, in my prior years,
a homicide detective for a few years.
Also, I spent a couple years investigating
gang-related, mainly violent crime.
One of the things that I saw, often,
was a lot of the people
that I came in contact with
in my mind, and I'm not a psychologist,
but I truly believe that there
were disabilities present
that had never been diagnosed.
And the reason that's so important,
in terms of from both a legal perspective
and as an investigator, you
really have to get a sense
of what you're dealing with,
because if you don't, it
can lead to some places
that you don't wanna go,
false confessions, fake confessions.
People wanna please.
A lot of times the
individuals with disabilities,
intellectual and developmental,
they wanna please,
and if you don't recognize that,
you can get a false confession.
So it's really, really
important, it's really,
really important that that
recognition takes place.
Feeling overwhelmed by police presence,
knowing how far to push,
not understanding
instructions or commands,
saying things that they
believe police wanna hear,
all these things can be mitigated
with proper training and
better understanding.
Now, when those encounters
are self-initiated
by the police officer,
oftentimes, it's because of
what we call either a reasonable suspicion
or sometimes probable cause
that some crime has been committed.
And, oftentimes, though,
the calls are relayed
from people in the public, the dispatch.
Now, we've all seen calls,
particularly lately,
with people that called
in on an individual
thinking one thing, and
some of them have been
a little bit over the top in terms of
what I think to be implicit biases.
And when we respond to these calls,
we really have to be able
to make our own assessment.
It is important what the
caller is seeing and saying
and all that, but we have to be prepared
and have our officers
have the skills needed
to both respond safely
and to really ferret out
fact from fiction, bias from reality,
and in terms of the
special needs population,
I think that's even more important,
because there are a lot of implicit biases
when it comes to special
needs individuals.
Bias by proxy is what I'm talking about.
So I call the police,
and I see an individual
that I think is doing something
suspicious or whatever,
what's shaping my perception?
How much have I been trained on this?
If I see somebody that has Down syndrome
and they're wobbling, and
I think they're either
under the influence or
mentally impaired or whatever,
am I taking the extra
time to really understand
what it is that I'm seeing
before I call dispatch to have an officer.
Oftentimes, I will tell you, people don't.
They call, and we get there.
So it's really incumbent
upon us to be able
to filter through all that.
And according to the Vera Institute,
bias by proxy poses a major challenge
to officers responding to calls.
And this was a 2008
opinion, so it's a little
over 10 years old, but Dale Larson,
who was a professor at
the UCLA School of Law,
he made it his mission
to support expanding
federal protections for individuals
with developmental disabilities.
He felt that implicit bias
with people with disabilities
is one of the strongest
types of implicit bias
in our society, he felt
that strongly about it.
And it does play a role in how we respond.
We respond to what is on
the screen in front of us,
and oftentimes, if that
body of information
that's on the screen in front of us
is driven by implicit bias, it may impact
the way that we respond to things.
So we have to be able to discern.
I'll go back to what I said earlier.
We, as police officers,
have to be able to discern.
And, gonna show you this training video
that our training staff put together.
Again, this is another
piece of our training
of how we're dealing with this issue.
John, if you would play the video, please.
John, if you'll play...
(car engine)
(door opening)
- [Police Officer] Hi, ma'am,
are you the one that called?
- Yes, I am.
- What's happened?
- Oh, I don't know, that
guy over there just came
into my store and was
walking around, really odd,
and picking things up
and putting 'em down,
and I didn't know what he was doing.
Then I went over to kinda check
and he just turned around
and hit me really hard.
I guess he bumped into me,
but he didn't say, he didn't
even seem to be aware of it,
he didn't say, excuse me,
he's sorry, or anything.
He just took the chips he had in his hand
and he walked out of the store.
- Are you hurt at all?
- [Woman] No.
- [Police Officer] Do
you need an ambulance?
- [Woman] No.
- Okay, where is he now?
- He's down there.
He's standing down there.
That guy with the green,
whatever it is, that bag.
- Okay, ma'am, right here, we'll come back
and talk to you.
- All right.
- [Police Officer] Hi sir, can you get
your hands outta your pockets?
- Yeah.
- This woman over here is
claiming that you hit her.
- No.
- [Police Officer] She also said you took
something from the store.
- I couldn't even pass.
- All right, how old are you?
- 20.
- What's your name?
- Hero.
- Hero, okay.
And what's your last name.
- Medina.
- Do you live around here?
- Not really, somewhere else in the city.
- [Police Officer] Well,
Hero, we're just concerned,
because she feels like you
bumped into her on purpose.
And then you're saying
you didn't bump into her
on purpose, I guess.
But we're just trying to find out
why she might feel like that.
Now, she's thinking you took
the bag of chips on purpose.
- I can give it back.
- Hero, are you diagnosed with anything?
Are you taking any medications?
- I have autism.
- That explains it.
- All right, three Adam 13...
- The role of the police officer
is one of the most complicated in society.
You're asked to respond to numerous calls
on a daily basis and make effective
and ethical decisions using
your training and experience.
Consider the scene we just witnessed.
How many calls for service
have you responded to
which begin almost exactly like this?
How much do you really know walking in?
Sometimes the most important
piece of information
is the one you don't have access to.
Autism spectrum disorder
is extremely common,
but it might not always be clear
when you're encountering it.
You police a large and diverse community.
As police officers, you
have a duty to treat
all members of the community with respect,
provide trust, be neutral
in your encounters,
and provide every person a voice.
In the next few minutes
we will discuss autism,
how this condition manifests itself,
and the ways that police
officers can safely
and effectively serve these
members of our community.
- So again, this is just
a portion of the video
that we give our officers so they have
a better understanding of how
to respond, how to encounter.
I'm gonna do a public safety
announcement plug here,
so for those of you that,
and many people in this room
probably are more educated
than the average individual
on really understanding what you're seeing
in terms of dealing with a person
with an intellectual or
developmental disability.
What I would ask, from a
public service perspective,
is as much as you have
conversations with your friends,
neighbors, loved ones, is
to have those conversations.
Help educate, because bias
by proxy is a problem for us.
I can tell you that.
People call on what they
believe is happening,
and we have to respond to it.
And as much as we train and
try to provide the tools
for our officers to recognize what it is
that they're dealing with,
we still get the calls.
There is a need for
educating the general public
to take the time and try
to determine what you got
before you make the call.
So what I ask of the audience
is have those conversations.
Please continue to have
those conversations.
Many of you are educators,
many of you work in this world,
it's a message that needs to be spread
in terms of implicit bias,
taking the time to recognize
what you're looking at,
so you don't make a bad situation
worse by your own biases.
And that's something that I think,
as a society, we gotta get better at.
What all this is about
for us is we wanna prepare
our officers to prevent
the need to use force,
not to react to these types
of situations by using force.
That training video that Officer Padilla
and Officer Bannity, with
the gentleman with autism,
those situations often go sideways
just because there's no awareness
of what is in front of you.
There's no awareness that
the person has autism
or whatever the issue is,
and without awareness,
you have more probability
of things going sideways.
So the training is definitely
needed and necessary,
and that's why we do it.
We wanna prevent these
situations form escalating
to a point where they get to a situation
where force has to be used
to get it back under control.
According to a report
by the Police Executive
Research Forum, better known as PERF,
nearly all the use of force incidents
that have proven to be controversial,
and this study was over a number of years,
the officers' actions
reflected their training.
And that's a true axiom in policing.
How you train is how you're gonna react.
So the better we train, the
better understanding we have,
the better reaction you should
expect and demand from us.
The mindset of policing
in general has changed
over the last few years
from this warrior mentality
of going in and being
the triumphant warrior
to one of a guardian, one that is
a caretaker of the community.
At the San Francisco Police Department,
we've spent a lot of
time over the last year
developing a strategy statement,
and what we came up with,
and this was many members
of the department that participated is
we wanna stand for safety
with respect for all, for all,
disabled or not, typical for all.
And this our guiding strategy.
We wanna stand for safety with respect,
and in order to do that, we have to train,
we have to understand.
So part of that strategy includes engaging
in just, transparent, unbiased,
and responsive policing,
and again, bias is a big
part of this population.
There are a lot of biases
in terms of how people view
people with intellectual and
developmental disabilities.
We wanna do so in the spirit of dignity
and collaboration with the community.
And that's a really important piece.
That video would not have been produced,
I know I gave Captain
Moore thanks for this,
but there are a lot of other people,
community partners, that made this happen.
And that had a lot more
to bring to the table
than we did in terms of expertise.
So collaboration and partnership is key
in terms of really
policing getting better.
And then we wanna maintain and build trust
and respect as the guardians
of constitutional human rights.
And I think that's just very basic,
but it's really as simple as that for us.
So how are we gonna accomplish that?
Training, and what you
see in front of you,
and I'll go through this part quickly,
is the San Francisco Police Department's
level of training compared
to national statistics,
and I'm proud to say
that our training levels
are in the orange graphs.
So we do a lot more than
what's required of us,
but we do that because we
wanna be better at what we do,
particularly when it comes to this issue.
It comes at a cost, though.
When officers are sitting in training,
they're not in the field,
and that's this tension
that everybody wants to deal with now.
I get calls every day about I wanna see
more officers in my community.
What they don't know
is if we don't sit down
in the academy and do
this type of training,
the service that you
get is gonna be diluted
and we could be better.
So we wanna be responsive,
but we also wanna be professional,
and we wanna be the best that we can be
in terms of handling the calls
and the community needs
that we need to handle.
So training is a very, very
important part of that,
and as you see, I think we really
put our money where our mouths are
when it comes to that issue.
Some of our specialized
training, autism training,
crisis intervention, procedural justice,
principled policing and implicit bias,
managing implicit bias.
I just signed a memo last night.
We're about to re-institute another round
of implicit bias training.
Creating an inclusive environment,
just signed that memo last night as well.
Use of force, and critical thinking.
Critical thinking is really important,
because, like I said, a lot of times,
we get thrust into a
very volatile situation,
and naturally, you react.
Some of it is instinctive,
particularly when you feel
that somebody's life is in
danger, particularly your own.
You react, and how we
react in that situation
has to be coordinated.
So we just instituted
another block of training
for our troops on critical mindset,
making sure that we're coordinated,
and making sure that
we're thinking critically,
making sure that somebody is
there to slow things down.
And that is really important,
particularly when it comes to this issue,
'cause slowing things down
usually yields better results.
Our crisis intervention training,
and I won't go into too
much detail on that,
but we spend, we have a 40
hour block and a 10 hour block.
Our goal is to train the
entire police department
over the next couple years.
And some of the key issues there:
de-escalation versus
escalation, voice neutrality,
listening, tonal
communication atmospheres,
all of those things when
it comes to, particularly,
autism and Asperger's,
those things matter.
They matter greatly, so
the better we are at it,
the better our response is gonna be.
Promoting procedural justice.
For a short definition, procedural justice
really gets to fairness.
How are we treating people?
Based on the situation,
is what we're doing
perceived as fair?
And there's a whole block of training
that goes into that, so our
officers really understand
the core principles and
tenets of procedural justice,
creating a fair environment for everybody.
Re-thinking, re-engineering, re-training.
It has to be a systematic approach
to reducing the frequency of what we saw
in these videos from happening.
It has to be systematic.
It has to be ingrained in
the culture and the DNA
of our department, and that's
what we're trying to do.
That's the reason that these videos
and all this training that
I'm talking about exist
is because how we train
becomes our behavior.
And we want our behaviors to be consistent
with our values, and that goes back
to treating people with respect.
- [Woman Off Camera] I
realize it's difficult
to cut off an armed man.
(audience laughs)
I want you to keep on talking,
but we've got another speaker,
and thank you so much.
- Okay, so I will skip to...
(audience laughs)
That one.
(audience laughs and applauds)